Je passe un bon moment
mec il y a une tempête pour de vrai
pourquoi on à fait ça maintenant
Clément : Attends recule un peu
Il y a la pluie après Clément, je peux pas, toi recule.
Les amis j'espère que vous allez bien, que vous passez de bonne vacance, que vous faîtes les zigotos,
en colo, au travail, à l'école, en faisant vos devoirs, je sais pas ce que vous faîtes.
Ecoutez, nous on est au canada avec Clément vous le savez surement si vous me suivez sur les réseaux sociaux, si vous êtes des gens biens.
Parce que j'avais posté deux photos je crois ou trois mais pas beaucoup mais en peu quand même.
Qu'est-ce qu'ont fout au Canada ? Et au Quebec plus particulièrement ?
Et bah écoutez, l'office du tourisme du Canada nous à invité ici,
pendant une semaine pour faire plein d'activités de ouf à travers trois régions du Québec.
La mauvaise et bonne nouvelle quand même parce que s'est avec des bonnes vidéos
s'est que les les vlogs sortiront en septembre et pas maintenant.
T'es déçu, c'est normal.
Clément : Allez gros vite, j'me prends plein de flotte le temps de parler *rire*
Pourquoi j'fais cette vidéo pour vous prévenir du coup que que *rire*
que ça fait 7 jours qu'on est au Canada et que là je m'en vais à Toronto pendant sept jours en off vraiment, en vacances
On s'est fait un tatouage au Canada, regardez par David Kotter
J'ai été un vrai bonhomme, j'ai pas du tout souffert
Petite anecdote drôle, heu j'ai découvert son taf grâce à Clément ici présent,
et je savais pas mais en fait c'est le tatoueur préféré de mon frère, mon frère like toutes ses photos sur Instagram !
Sois pas dégoûté Florent, ça va aller, David a pensé à toi mec,
il m'a donné un petit tatouage temporaire, que j'pourrai te prêter allègrement,
qui d'ailleurs ne peut plus marcher maintenant, vu qu'il vient de prendre 100g de pluie dessus *rires*
Voilà les amis c'est tout pour les news, je vous souhaite de bonnes vacances, je vous dis à dans une semaine environ.
Vous me connaissez je vais pas vous quitter là-dessus j'suis pas un FDP,
J'vais vous laisser sur un petit extrait de tout ce qu'on a pu faire au Québec en 7 jours,
j'vous le rappelle les vidéos sortiront en Septembre et j'vous dis à bientôt j'm'en vais !
Mais pas trop loin quand même, parce qu'il pleut sous cet arbre, donc là t'imagines bien que c'est chaud hein